joining me now is charlie gasparino from
fox business senior correspondent
charlie it's great to see you tonight
now i'm going to repeat bezos's question
i was reading a little bit there charlie
is this purposeful misdirection or just
a complete financial illiteracy
illiteracy of basic market dynamics
uh well it's uh there it's always been
involved but this is a particularly
economically
i don't want to say illiterate but a
president that has that lacks literacy
when it comes to the economy i mean it's
not just on this one i mean this is so
obvious
most of the gas station owners are small
business people they operate on thin
margins you know the minute that the
price in the on the on the uh futures
markets go down it's not reflected in
what they've already paid for the the
stuff that you're pumping in their tanks
so i mean and they're not trying to rip
people off mom and pops are not trying
to rip people off that's basic other
basic stuff is about you know raising
taxes on billionaires so you know we can
lower inflation that ain't gonna happen
either often you raise taxes on upper
income people it hits small businesses
the small businesses actually will pass
down that cost to uh to consumers so it
may increase inflation
i mean we could go on and on about this
um
listen it's a scary time in this country
and i'll tell you why
when i hear from my ceo sources who are
moderates or dems
who you know would go nuts every time
trump put out a tweet about something
and oh the world is coming to an end
they are really worried about joe biden
that he does not have the economic chops
the intellectual chops i should say to
deal with what could be coming at us we
could have a very serious problem here
we have inflation it may be coming down
but it's coming down because the economy
is starting to slow and it may be
slowing significantly and if you have
someone that's this economically obtuse
or vacuous or secure pick your adjective
um how are we really going to do this
and i think one of the problems is it's
not just that the president is just not
up up to par here when it comes to
dealing with the economy he surrounded
himself literally with ideologues of the
left i mean you can go up and down the
line think of the most economically
astute person in the in the white house
right now is probably brian deese brian
diese is the head of the nec national
economic council uh before he went to
washington he spent a couple years at
blackrock the big money management firm
now he wasn't there managing money and
handling portfolios and trading stocks
you know that would give him some some
relevant experience to for the economy
he was there pushing the company to
adopt esg environmental social
government standards not to make money
not to figure out markets to he was
essentially a green advocate within
blackrock he was proselytizing about
this
that is esg stuff and he's probably the
best guy they got janet yellen charlie
yeah i mean i could go down
she missed she misses everything when it
comes to inflation the economy she
printed money like crazy as fed charlie
charlie charlie you're being very
charitable or diplomatic or both because
at some point it's i'm getting that from
you a little bit but at some point
when does this become
[Music]
purposeful sabotage i mean it's not that
complicated how to how to get us back to
energy independence if you want but they
don't want that right i don't want that
they're clear it's an ideological loop
here i mean listen the the left controls
the biden administration on all sorts of
policies i just told you the head of the
nec is a lefty that you know
you know proselytized about esg goals
which essentially led to oil companies
cutting back on production i mean that's
one of the reasons um and you can go up
and down the line so you know it's a
scary situation we have inflation that
means the fed has to tighten tighten
stuff right it has to tighten the money
supply bring down demand on top of a
biden administration that is purposely
keeping supply low and so you have the
bet the worst of both worlds and that's
why you hear jamie dimon who's a
democrat the head of jpmorgan chase say
you know a storm is coming or a
hurricane he used something scary but
that's what that's that's pretty good
that's right jamie's jamie's all in in
china so we got that you got the chips
over there too charlie sorry hey charlie
great to see you great to have you on
the show anytime hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else